or Taiwan's pro-independence president
sighing Ren has won a second term
following national elections voters
backed sighs tough stance against the
islands large and powerful neighbor
China supporters began celebrating as
early results showed her Democratic
Progressive Party had won a comfortable
majority Tsai campaigned on protecting
Taiwan's independence against threats
from China the main opposition candidate
Hankou you conceded defeat he had
advocated for closer ties with China to
improve trade well let's bring in our
correspondents Phoebe Cong in Taipei and
Matthias Berliner in Beijing hi Phoebe
how have been people been reacting to
the results mattias building in beijing
let's bring you in as Phoebe said there
psy has been voted in after you know her
tough stance against China what's going
to happen to that relationship in light
of these results today
Beijing has been very clear that it did
not want her to win and it has
throughout the last four years applied a
lot of measures to put pressure on her
has lured away some of the very few
diplomatic ala allies that Taiwan has it
has curb the number of mainland tourists
that visit Taiwan economic pressure it
has put pressure on foreign companies to
mark Taiwan as a province of China in
all their materials and on their website
all this has not worked as we see today
yet we might see this more of the same
again and the reason is that Beijing has
made very clear it is a dogma for
Beijing not to compromise on what it
sees as its core issues and Taiwan
policy and the control over Taiwan is
definitely one of the core issues for
Beijing of course we need to think about
Hong Kong here Phebe in what way have
the antis in Hong Kong impacted the
result in Taiwan Chinese President Xi
Jinping's also mine Taiwan - a model but
the time for them to reject -
unification of China and it's also
values and this is also
in the past few months that the exercise
in wrestling it is an example like for
them to really how those as choice today
my tears just quickly how committed is
China to political union with Taiwan the
fact that the Communist Party could not
conquer Taiwan 70 years ago has
tarnished the narrative that Communist
Party has liberated and United the
country and it has been remained one of
the major issues of communist propaganda
here so we or gaining control over
Taiwan would be seen by any leader what
would make any leader go into history
and Xi Jinping has been clear has made
clear his ambitions to be the leader who
brings car Taiwan under the control of
the Communist Party this is an important
ideological issue
okay Matias building in Beijing and
Phoebe Kong in Taipei thank you